[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar tips and tricks when using
filter plates of spin devices with
nucleic acid protein purification and
cloning applications
i am marie stone of lab roots and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by paul life sciences
to learn more visit paul.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
we you may also submit any technical
issues here as well if you have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation
in addition to submitting questions we
encourage you to answer poll questions
when they are posted
click on the option that best describes
your answer
i'd like to now welcome our speaker
dr lima fabulee
phd global product manager for molecular
laboratory product portfolio at paul
corporation
lima you may now begin your presentation
thank you marie
good morning everybody and thanks so
much for joining this webinar uh today
so as marie introduced already my name
is lima and i'm a global product manager
for molecular product portfolio at paul
corporation
and today's presentation is based on the
filter plates and centrifugal spin
devices
that can be used for a various
life sciences research applications
however today i will be focusing on the
nucleic acid
extraction and purification protein
purification and cloning applications
so just before i begin my presentation
i would like to better understand the
audience that we have today or that
joins us today and you should see on
your screens a quick pause survey coming
up so if you can just take a moment and
answer that sorry that would be great
and i'll just give you a couple moments
before we begin the presentation
i see couple attendees already
participating
thank you
all right so i see that uh most
participants actually are based at
biotechnology internship following by
academia
um great thank you so much for your
participation so let's just move on i do
have to show this legal disclaimer uh
which claims that paul labor products
and the products that i will be talking
about today
are designed for professional laboratory
applications only so these products are
not approved for use in medical clinical
surgical or other patient protection
applications it is not it is also not
suitable for use in biopharmaceutical
manufacturing or production
so during today's presentation i would
like to start uh by just really a brief
introduction
on paul corporation for those who are
not familiar with the company
then i will go over
very briefly sample preparation
filtration and separation basics we'll
go over filter plate product family
overview following by the centrifugal
spin devices product overview and then
we'll talk a little bit about
what you should look at when it comes to
choosing the right membrane or filter
for your specific application we'll go
over some applications as well as
performance data and study examples
and at the end of the presentation we
would have a q a session so please feel
free to post uh your questions
um via chat that you see on your left
hand side of the screen throughout the
presentations which i will answer at the
end
so paul corporation of paul labs is a
global company and our expertise is in
filtration separation and sample
preparation solutions
and
our products can be grouped into two
major groups which are quality control
and life sciences research and when we
talk about equality control
we are specializing in products for
environmental monitoring micro qc or
sterility qc
as well as analytical chemistry or
analytical qc for
product validation
now when we talk about the life sciences
research we are talking about the
products that are designed for molecular
applications and some of the
applications include such as nucleic
acid extraction and purification protein
purification satellite development cloud
optimization selection and so many more
that i will show you uh as we go
along
so when i talk about sample preparation
purification and filtration
um of course this is not the area where
you would like to spend a lot of time
thinking about it and putting a lot of
energy into it however i think it's
really important to understand the
filtration methods uh because by
selecting the right method for your
application um
it may affect your outcome or initially
data and even your molecule quality
and when we think about the filtration
we are thinking about two major aspects
of the filtration which are
microfiltration and ultrafiltration
and if you look at that
image on the right hand side of your
screen
it may help you to better understand the
difference between those two filtration
methods so as you can see micro
filtration is really in order to remove
larger size particulars or particles
everything that is uh or
is
larger than 0.1 micron in size
and those particles could be colloids
cells
bacteria viruses you would use
microfiltration filter if you want to
remove gross particulates and raw cells
as an example
now if we talk about the ultrafiltration
we are talking about small size
molecules and particulate removal or
even separation so anything that is
smaller than 0.1 micron
we would be using ultrafiltration
filters and again when we talk about the
ultrafiltration we are thinking about uh
nucleic acids and proteins so we're
talking about the molecules at molecular
level
if you look at some of the main
applications for microfiltration
it will be pre-filtration sterile
filtration and of course cell-based
assays whereas
some of the main applications that will
be used on the ultrafiltration it would
be concentration diafiltration which is
really mainly buffer exchanges as well
as size fractionation
now what is really nice about the
filtration or one of the biggest benefit
of the filtration
is that the method is mechanical and
it's not requiring any harsh chemicals
to be used in order to remove or
separate your molecules
which is a big thing especially if
you're working with the nucleic acids or
proteins because you do not want to
change your protein structure or
function
um
if you would use some harsh chemicals in
that filtration method so indeed
filtration has a huge advantage
to
compare to other separation or
filtration methods that are available
that are require harsh chemicals to be
used
now if we think about the
microfiltration a little bit further
as as i mentioned again earlier so this
method is used for removal of the larger
particulates
and
what
you really need to think when when it
comes to membrane selection or filter
selection is two critical parameters so
you would need to think about the pore
size
as well as effective filtration area
now the pore size
is just really
tells you or it would depend in terms of
what exactly you're trying to filter
whereas the effective filtration area
would depend
on how much of the sample you would like
to filter and once again if you look at
that table on the right hand side
um you could see various sizes of the
pores
pores or membrane pore sizes listed and
if we kind of look from the bottom
first step that has depth media and
glass fiber
and we move up those steps all the way
to 0.1 micron pore size containing media
we see that the usage of those membranes
significantly reduces
so for example
we'll be using death media to remove
large
particles from the sample
just to clean up that sample before we
would
move let's say to this sterile
filtration
so again that def media photo would be
used in many more applications compared
to the sterile filtration filter
what's really nice is that paul actually
has to offer a dual layer membrane in
some of our devices
and what that really means that a single
device has two layer membranes and what
that allows you is that we can perform
two filtration steps in a single one
step and a single device so again as
example um these membranes could be such
as
containing death media over sterile
filter again that meat death media would
be used for large particle removal
before the sample is further cleaned up
uh using a sterile filtration filter
just to really remove that bacteria
which is mainly used for
now let's move on into filter plates
product family overview so over here you
can see um listed
parameters and specifications that our
filter plates come in and of course we
have a huge selection of those filter
plates available that do range in
throughput membrane pore size as well as
design and when we talk about the
throughput we do offer 24 96 and 384
well filter plates of course all those
plates also vary in the
volume that sample can be processed
and membrane and post size now
most of the filter plates
um
are designed for a specific application
um and that's why the membrane and pore
size would be specific for that
particular application however we do
have some general and universal photos
that i will cover later on and with
regards to the design um it's a crucial
point and i'll talk a little bit about
it in a few moments
especially if you're performing a high
throughput analysis using automated or
robotic systems
and i would like to run another poll
very quickly uh to see really
what type of
plates you are using in your research or
routinely use in your lab and if you can
take a moment and answer that question
that would be great
so once again i'll just give a few
moments and again i see already uh
results popping up and it's not
surprising uh right now 100
uh answers are based on the 96 well
played um it's not surprising at all for
us as well
because that is the play that
we see our end users using most
so thank you for the participation
different cuts to the uh
plate selection consideration um
i would like to talk about three things
or three aspects that may help you when
it comes to
what or which filter plate i should
select and these are really
straightforward things that i will
mention first of all is a throughput uh
really just to know if you're working
with
a high throughput
sort of
workflows that you are processing many
samples of course 384 plate or 96 well
plate would be the one to use and if
you're working with less samples 24 wall
plate would be ideal solution and again
you would need to think about your
sample volume and here it's not only
about the starting sample volume but
also recovered volumes so just to think
about
how much of the recovered sample you
would need to perform your downstream
analysis maybe you'll be using the same
sample for several applications so just
keep that in mind and again downstream
analysis as i already mentioned just
knowing by what exactly you're trying to
achieve is the concentrate molecules to
remove molecules or separate molecules
will help to really
select the right filter plate for you
if we look at deep filter plate designs
and i did mention this is a one of the
most important aspects of the filter
place that paul has to offer i would
like to begin with the rigid
construction so what that really
construction means or the design of the
plate is that
our place are strong
in and
just that rigid constructions prevents
the potential flexing and bending and
potentially jamming your automated
systems and is super important when you
are working with the
robotic systems as you know robotic arm
has to handle the place and move around
so just preventing bending and flexing
the plate is important
another thing is our place come in
smooth well design and what that really
means is that um
is
it's a big thing especially if you're
working with lower sample volumes for
example with 384 well plays that have up
to 100 microliters of total volume
the smooth well design prevents from
sample getting caught outside of the
wells and potentially losing it
and again this smooth wall design is a
great option whenever you're working
with resin screening as well bead bait
analysis so it does prevent that
efficient sample recovery process
another thing to consider when it comes
to the filter plates those plates do
come in two
outlet tip designs so we do offer short
and long outlet tips
and you can see on the right hand side
in those blue circles a schematic
representation of that short and long
tip and the short tip
plate would be used in the cases where
the
plate height is a crucial
aspect
however we have seen that most our users
do use that long tip containing outlet
plates because those long tips
do minimize the risk of cross
contamination because visually you could
see those tips
sitting in the receiver plate and that
way it is possible to just really
eliminate potential crosstalk from
samples
our plates are micro uh microplate
standards and as i mentioned are
automated friendly and lastly we do uh
offer
serial barcodes on the plates which i
think also important especially if
you're working with the high tripod
applications you do want to
track your samples as well as plates and
membranes that we use in that particular
application
once again when it comes to the filter
plates uh for the sample preparation and
filtration applications it's really
simple and easy operation and the filter
please that i've been talking about
um
the the product family is called akra
prep and all this filter place or most
of them can be uh processed using
different methods of course
centrifugation positive pressure systems
can be applied for the 24
well filter plates as well as vacuum
system
and as you can see on the right hand
side there's a just really three step
example just to show you how it is easy
to process and filtrate sample using
vacuum system
in this particular case a vacuum
manifold and you can see a picture in
the center of the slide that is the
system that also is offered by paul labs
so a whole workload starts by adding
your receiver plate inside the vacuum
manifold and then the sample plate is
placed on the top of it
then sample is loaded into the plate
vacuum is applied your sample is passed
through the membrane or filter
and then vacuum is released and then you
are able to remove your sample plate as
well as receiver plate
simple and it's a fast process
we'll move on now on the centrifugal
spin devices so over here you can see an
overview of the spin devices that we
have to offer and again these devices do
range in terms of the processing volume
ranging from 50 microliters and all the
way to 60 ml for those applications that
require larger volume processing
spin devices also vary in terms of the
membrane that
these
devices come in but we do
address
micro filtration as well as as well as
ultra filtration applications
i would like to talk a little bit
more about this centrifugal devices
structure and we will start with the
nano steps as you can see on the left
hand side
so the nanoset has a
filtrate receiver tube which is
really looking very similar to the 1.5
mil eppendorf tube and then it does have
a sample reservoir which contains
membrane of course the sample reservoir
is added into the filter receiver before
that device can be used for filtration
if if we look at the right hand side for
microsoft and microsoft
structure again we do have similar
parts we have a filtration receiver tube
sample reservoir
membrane paddle and a cap
now
competitors out there also offers
similar devices when it comes to the
centrifugal devices
however
there is a big difference with the
competitor membrane and our membrane
incorporated on a paddle
now
the competitor spin devices do have a
v-shape membrane
whereas in our cases that membrane is
incorporated on a paddle or paddle
design membrane which actually goes up
and down in sample reservoir so for
example if you are spinning uh proteins
and using v-shaped membrane
uh you potentially or artificially can
create protein gradient
uh which can cause protein crash outs
and aggregates whereas using that paddle
design the membrane is incorporated on a
paddle we are able to avoid the
potential aggregate protein aggregation
and ultimately the protein recovery will
be much higher compared to the v-shaped
membranes
this is a summary table
summarizing
the subject centrifugal spin devices
that we have to offer and as you can see
as i mentioned already they do range in
terms of the sample volume you could
also see the housing and paddle material
that used to manufacture these devices
different filter media or
filters as well as uh molecular weight
cut off some pore sizes as well
representing for each of those devices
but then i would like to talk a little
bit more about the membranes of filters
in general and i think this table would
summarize the best
so you could see on the left hand side
we do have a selection of different
filters available
that come in either filter place spin
devices or both
and
mainly these
membranes are designed for a specific
application and as you can see the
application listed in a table
however there are couple that we would
uh recommend to use for any sort of
general filtration and those would be
super as well as ww ptfe membrane or
and as well as a ww-ptfe membrane
can be used or we would call it as a
universal membrane
so if it's a hydrophilic ptfe membrane
that is suitable for most applications
and i would highly recommend just to
have that membrane available in the lab
whenever you're working with uh any sort
of application now of course if you're
working with specifically with organic
solvents
ptfe membrane would be more suitable if
you're working with
nucleic acid as well as protein
extraction and purification we do have a
specific membrane called nucleic acid
binding membrane and so on for example
even if you are working with iron
exchange applications we do have a
negatively and positive charge membranes
which called
mustang um and as i mentioned so we do
have membranes that are designed for
specific applications as well as general
membranes
so before i move on into the
applications i would like to run another
paul survey question just asking
which particular applications you are
performing in your lab
and again i'll just give a couple
moments for you to participate before we
move on
i can see that protein concentration and
purification is the most commonly
used application based on our audience
results
and stylizes
clarification as well as nucleic acid
extraction purification
thank you thank you
okay so again in terms of the
applications filter plays as well as
centrifugal spin devices can be used in
so many different applications i
literally ran out of space just typing
those applications in the blue box below
and as you can see there are so many
ranging from nucleic acid extraction
purifications resin screening
but i'm not going to mention all of them
here i do have some uh performance data
and study examples that will cover some
of them
so and we're just moving on into the
performance data and first example that
i would like to show to you is based on
the
um
clarification and sterile filtration
performed using 24
uh well filter plate containing that
dual layer membrane so two membranes
incorporated in a single well
and at this particular case we use the
mammalian show cell cultures and we were
looking for protein recovery
now as you can see in a table the actual
results look really great so we looked
at the intact cells
and this static material as you can see
uh was quite condensed and concentrated
cell culture and what we looked at was
the turbidity so turbidity can be used
to measure pre and pro filtration which
really tells us how well we are removing
uh
cells that we are not interested in and
as you can see at the beginning we see
that turbidity was measured about 19 to
2600
but then after the filtration which we
also performed in centrifugation as well
as vacuum
manifold using method we can see that
that turbidity significantly dropped
which really indicates to us that we
were able to eliminate unwanted cells
but you may ask okay well we remove the
unwanted cells but doesn't mean that we
also remove protein now the answer is no
because we did measure protein recovery
in percentage and you can see
highlighted in blue where we can see for
this particular assay mammalian chose
cell cultures intact cells and we see
more than 95 protein recovery using 24
filter plate containing those two
membranes so we had a clarification
memory which removed those bigger
particles and then we used the sterile
filtration just to clear up and to
recover protein at the end
similar situation uh or similar study we
performed using yeast uh cultures as
well as bacterial cultures the same
exact filter plate uh we looked at the
turbidity and protein recovery and we
also
tested decentrification as well as
vacuum methods and this time we looked
at intact cells as well as life cells
again as you can see the turbidity from
really damp cell lines drop
significantly to the uh really low
numbers just telling us that we
successfully removed unwanted big
particles or those cells raw cells
and then if we look at the protein
recovery again we are able to obtain a
high quality and yield protein for
uh for any relay filtration method that
it was used for intact as well as size
uh lysis
lysis cells
another performance example that i would
like to show you is based on the
molecule retention
so in this particular case once again we
use the 24
well filter plate but this time
containing different membranes so it's
our omega based membrane because what
we're trying to perform is of
ultrafiltration we're talking at
molecular level and we're talking um
in terms of the pore size in molecular
weight cutoffs instead of the micro
microns
so what we did we had a sample that had
a variety or a range of different
molecules mixed together and you can see
those molecules listed in a table on the
right hand side and approximately size
of those molecules in kilodaltons
we applied or we
use a centrifugation vacuum and positive
pressure filtration methods in this case
uh just to compare which method performs
better
and we looked at the retention of a
particular molecule
now i know this is a busy table
or graph that you can see on your
screens
but the take home message it would be
just really it's really important to
select the right
membrane with the right molecular weight
cut off
in order to obtain the molecule of
interest
and as an example if we look at the
vitamin b12 which
molecule is about 1.4 in kilodaltons
if we use the membrane with molecular
weight cut off one we are able to retain
that molecule without any issues and
similar situation if we would use a
membrane containing molecular weight
three but if we look at the membrane
with molecular weight 10
the
third graph really from your left
we can see that vitamin b is no longer
present we are really using it so that
just really tells you how important it
is to know which particular molecular
weight membrane i should use and what
i'm aiming to achieve
over here we have an example on the
chromatography
sorbent screening
as well as resin screening and resin
condition screening which can be used
one of the methods from nucleic acids
and protein purification
now what's really nice is by using
plates and this particular membrane that
we would recommend super membrane does
come in 24 well plate but as well as 96
well blade if you are looking for a
scale up applications
but what the flute uplift allows you is
to screen
many different resin conditions
and
and and and that way you are able to
optimize chromatography resin as well as
purification conditions rapidly
and also another thing is that you don't
need to use much of the sample which is
great
we do have a really nice
technical note
which is
walking you through step by step in
terms of the how to use the
chromatography application in the filter
plates so if you are interested will be
able to provide that technical note or
you can even download from the paul's
website
and as i mentioned previously a very
specific ion exchange chromatography
based membrane also is available for
those specific applications
let's talk a little bit about the
passivation and really what positivation
is is just
additional step that you would need to
perform in order to potentially increase
your protein recovery and we do hear
some feedback from the field where
customers mentioning that
the protein recovery is not great
so this study example just really
confirms that performing that additional
step the passivation of pre-treatment of
the membrane can significantly improve
prod protein recovery so in this
particular case what we did um we used a
nanospin centrifugal device with a
specific membrane that had a molecular
weight cut off on 30k
and we used bsa protein which is our
recovery process of protein of interest
which was diluted into concentrations
0.1 and 1 micrograms per micro per mil
and
we also prepared three different uh
passivation buffers or solutions and we
did test at one percent bsa five percent
sds and five percent twin buffers in
this particular experiment but as you
can see below that uh data graph there
are other
um position buffers that you would be
able to use
and i should in addition to the ones
that we tested a whole process is really
simple and straightforward and it just
starts by adding that passivation buffer
prepared into the spin device
leave it to
incubate at room temperature for a while
then it is rinsed with water and added
your protein of interest or sample that
needs to be
recovered and by spinning down that
device we're able to recover protein
with a much higher recovery percentage
when con when compared to the untreated
samples as you can see in that table
briefly i would like to touch device at
clearance filter plates and i think it's
really important just because we are
talking about the nucleic acid
extractions and purification
as well as
plasmid dna
recovery so in some cases the
molecules of interest or in order to
obtain molecules of interest
we must lysate cells to start with and
then again what that would entirely us
is just really cleaning or removing
those lysate cells
and then recovering the cells of
interest or lysid cells
so in this particular case what we are
really performing is the pre-filtration
step and then a further cleanup step
again when we talk about the lyset
clearance we want to look at the
efficiency how well we can separate
and remove the unwanted cells and then
we want to look if we do have the
molecules of interest still remaining in
a sample
did we remove the molecules of entries
such as nucleic acids or plasmid dna or
not so again we do have data to support
that using our filter plates and spin
devices that this particular membrane we
are able to efficiently remove unwanted
cells and as you can see on the top
graph
and a whole this process is measured in
optical diameter
and then
once those unwanted cells are removed we
want to really look for the recovery and
again in this particular case what we
did we compared pole product to some of
the competitor products and you can see
from the graph showing that using pole
product we are able to recover a higher
concentration of percentage of molecules
of interest
when we talk about the nucleic acid
extraction and purification i did
mention we do have a specific membrane
called nba or nucleic acid binding
membrane which are available
in filter plates as well as nanosub
devices or centrifugal devices
but what we are talking here about is
plasmid dna genomic dna and rna
extraction and purification
so once again we want to see really the
efficiency in terms of the extraction of
those nucleic acids but then
the quality of those molecules and as
you can see the molecule or the quality
of the octane molecules is high enough
to perform
further downstream analysis that are
listed in the boxes ranging from really
just pcl or qpc applications all the way
to ngs or sequencing as well as north
and blotting applications as well as
sanji sequencing
what's really nice is that using
nanosaps as an example
the consumable
and combining those consumables with
commercially available
reagents or kits or even using your own
made in-house made reagents for
extraction of purification analysis
you are able to obtain high quality
molecules which is obviously less
expensive and we do have available
protocols um that also could walk you
through step-by-step guide how to
perform
that workflow also and how to make those
reagents if you are
looking into making reagents in-house
we regasted the plasma dna
extraction i just wanted to show you the
quality of the plasmid dna that was able
to obtain using the place and spin
devices
that also
is suitable for use for downstream
analysis such as restriction digestion
and cloning applications as well as as
sequencing or sanjay sequencing and you
can see at the bottom of that slide
there is a snapshot of the sequence data
which shows full length leads and really
showing no
no interference or quality issues with a
starting material
and very similar situation with the
genomic dna but in this case what we did
we
used spin devices or filter plates to
extract genomic dna from
show cell lines as well as hack
cell lines and we compare that quality
with our commercially available kits if
you would using commercially available
kits and as you can see from the data
there is no really difference in terms
of the quality of genomic dna that can
be obtained using our
consumables in fact even for the show
lines we can even see slightly higher
concentration when compared to the
commercially available kits
similar situation with the rna
extraction
again we looked at um
the quality of rna obtained using our
products compared to the commercially
available
kits but this time we also compared rna
extracted using commercially available
reagents and in-house developed reagents
and once again the quality of rna
obtained is great it's really high
quality and there is no really
difference between using spin devices or
plates leads
compared to the commercially available
kits
and lastly i would like to talk about
the molecular cloning workflow
and as you may know the cloning really
um
contains so many different steps ranging
from
isolation of the fragment from agarose
gel restriction digestions ligation
transfection transformation
all through that uh transformed cell
line of interest now again to perform
all these steps you may need
different kits
in order to obtain um or to perform that
step
and if you do need to have a different
kit for each of the steps this may
become a costly process and of course
time-consuming now this is way really
nice that paul has to offer a single
solution
to go through the cloning workflow
as an example using spin devices and
again we have a really nice application
node that walks you through step-by-step
guide how to perform cloning workflow
using spin devices and
just as an example i would like to show
you just couple of those um in this
particular case what we're using spin
device is for purification or isolation
and purification of dna from the gel
slice
and again as you can see it's just a
two-step process really straightforward
and simple to perform in order to obtain
that purified dna from the gel
so it begins really by having that gel
slice macerated and added into this spin
device that contains a microfiltration
filter to start with
and just really adding that
that
gel containing dna into the spin device
then spinning down and our
gel buffer containing dna will be passed
through
through the tube whereas the
bigger particles of the gels would be
caught on top of the membrane that can
be discarded but then dna containing uh
gel buffer is transferred into a second
type of spin device which contains
ultrafiltration media
and then
really by spinning down that solution
we're able to recover purified dna
just using spin devices
again um
in terms of the dna recovery we were
able to measure that using nanos of 100
k
or molecular weight equals to 100
kilodaltons
and it was greater than 90
so once again just a great solution
using spin devices in terms of dna
recovery and isolation from gel buffer
for the cloning applications
and lastly
again spin devices can be used for rapid
cloning of pcr products what's really
nice in this case is that restriction
and ligation steps can be performed in a
single device so what you would just
really need to add is your plasmid your
dna fragment that you would like to
clone restriction enzyme leave it to
incubate then spin down perform several
washes add buffer and ligase
spin down again and let that ligase to
to take effect and end product will be
the ligase transformed uh products and
in this particular for example uh
transform bacteria
using spin devices you are able to
reduce the number of manipulations and
again plastic so you need to use less
plastics to obtain the same results
and again this particular protocol is
suitable for most standard pci cloning
procedures
as the
quality of the transformative
product is
good
and with that i would like to thank you
for your attention and joining us today
and before i move on and answering any
questions i would like to run last paul
uh just really looking for your feedback
in terms of the webinar um
and if you could take a moment
to answer that survey it would be
appreciated
and one more thing i would like to
mention that you do see on your screens
on the right hand side the resources tab
where you are able to
download additional resources additional
collateral
based on the filter plate family in
terms of the selection guide as well as
uh the differences in terms of choosing
um different membrane with the molecular
weight cutoffs and two nice application
notes reporting some actual studies
based on using 24
filter
24 well filter plates
and thank you very much for those who
participated in a survey
and with that i would be more than happy
to answer any questions
thank you leima for your informative
presentation
we also have jorgen de haan application
scientist at paul corporation joining us
for the q a session
so we'll now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
so let's get started
our first question
yeah is there any
ups are there any scale up application
notes available from 24 well sterile
filtration and clarification filter
plates
yes that's a good uh question um
so in terms of the application knows
you're gonna would you mind to chip in
here as your expert in terms of the
application notes
sure um so as far as like scale up um
with the
lysate clearance plate
we don't have really application node
from that perspective
but we
and actually for scale up
i think generally what we would look at
more is
using supercap depth filters like the
supercap 50 which
are available with the whole panoply of
different size depth filter media
and have the same configuration as used
for all our biotech depth filter
devices
so those would be more suitable uh when
you are thinking about scale up
all right thank you
um next question
excuse me what is the best way to
process filter plates centrifuge or
vacuum
good question um so in terms in uh which
particular method you're using would
depend on the application to start with
but i think the good thing or as a
reference to think about
if you're looking to
um
to pass through
solution that you want to to to use for
your downstream analysis
use centrifugation because obviously
your sample would be passed through the
filter and that liquid retained in the
tube would be used for downstream
analysis but
in any other applications i would say a
vacuum would be the method of choice
all right thank you
next question do i have to use the whole
plate once
short answer is no so again that's
really nice think about the filter place
if you don't have enough samples to run
you are not really wasting that blade
you are more than happy to you you can
use that filter plate for just a few
sample processing
but a good um
again process would be is just to cover
the remaining
wells with some kind of
uh
something that you are trying to avoid
to potentially contaminate those wealth
just keeping those
wells clean for further usage and and
you would be good to go so you don't
need to use a whole plate at once
if i may add lima
um
[Music]
using sort of ceiling film to
seal off i guess wells that aren't in
use would be
especially important also when you use
the filter plates on a vacuum manifold
or positive pressure manifold
with with a microfiltration application
just because
if you don't have liquid in those wells
they will suck false air and then
perform
[Music]
affect the performance of the wells that
you're trying to use
right thank you
next question
i have never seen a 24 well filter plate
how would i fit it into my workflow
again it would depend on the application
that you're working on but um i would
like to give you an example if you're
working with cell cultures so let's say
cell cultures may be grown in a 24
well
plates so in that case it will be really
easy for you to transfer those samples
directly into the 24 filter plate
because it's the same well numbers but
even though if you're using if you're
growing those cells in vessels or shakes
or flasks
you are able to
remove those samples in the plate and
i think again using that particular
plate for cell culture the good thing is
that our plates come in a higher volume
so up to 7 ml
allowing you to transfer more static
material
and using pleats
just eliminates potential errors
then you compare using individual spin
devices as an example
and that way you also can save time
you can also improve the recovery and as
i mentioned to reduce that potential
contamination risk
all right thank you
next question
is the 24 well filter plate different
from a deep well plate
so when we talk about it deep well plate
those particular plates typically have a
solid bottom
whereas the acroprap filter plates and
the filter plates that i was talking
about today
um
can be used with a solid bottom plate
whereas for example 24 filter plates do
come with a solid receiver plate whereas
96 and 284 does not but just because
these plates are really standard uh
micro plate standard design you will be
able to use with a standard
solid bottom plates um as a receiver
plates
all right and i'm not sure you're gonna
deal
do you want to add something in terms of
the
uh deep well plate and
our 24 ball plates
difference
i i think you answered that correctly in
the sense that
um
that that the deep well plate generally
is a solid bottom plate
and um i would say that's the as far as
dimensions goes the 24 well plate sort
of has a similar height as a as a
um a deep well plate
um yeah
great thank you
next question which plate has better
binding capacity in 96 well and 384 well
plates for dna and rna
okay so again
it usually depends on your application
and starting material
and i
do know we do we do have some
application notes
that does talk about the performance
based on sample type as well as the
nucleic acid desired
but
you're going would you have a better
answer to that i think it really just
depends on the sample time in terms of
which one would be better
um binding capacity
yeah so basically it there would be
plates with either
our nucleic acid binding plate which
sort of has a
silica type of material in it
or or glass fiber material
so for instance uh um if you want to
have the same performance in the 384
well played as you want as in 96 well
format and for instance part number 5072
for the 384 well played
and
8151 for the 96 well plate would have
the same type of media and you can sort
of have similar performance
um but all these plates um
would do well
for dna and rna applications yeah
all right great thank you
next question
do you have to buy special equipment for
the 24 well filter plates
the short answer is no and again just
because our plates uh were designed to
meet
micro plate standards
so you will be able to
use the 24
well containing uh filter plays with
your standard equipment
um
and again you don't need really to look
into something special in terms of these
centrifuges
it will be just really a standard
uh
again i think maybe just want to add
sorry jorgen i guess the height
um would need to be considered as i
mentioned we do have those plates coming
with short and longer outlet tips so as
long as the height of that plate is
compatible with your centrifuge or even
liquid handling systems you would be
okay
all right great thank
you and it looks like we have time for
one more question
are processing parameters the same for
all plates i.e will it take the same
time require the same speed etc
so typically time to pros and samples
will vary um depending on membrane type
membrane pore size as well as the
application
in addition to sample characteristics as
well so it just really depends on the
sample
so it would it would not be exactly the
same but we do have recommendations in
terms of what is the maximum volume that
you should use to start with and what
would be the speed if you're using
decentrification
and time that it needs to
optimally filter that sample
all right well thank you again lima and
jorgen for your time today and your
important research
do you have any final comments for our
audience
all right well thank you again lima and
jorgen for your time today we would also
like to thank lab roots and our sponsor
paul life sciences for underwriting
today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event
until next time take care everyone and
goodbye
you